Hello Freak bitches,
two or three stories.
And so you set up a perimeter around the
building.
Key people stationed in them.
Yup.
Uh,
guns at the windows looking out
constantly.
And it would be,
we take the building down and then they
would do a massive construction projects
in the middle of a combat zone.
So these army engineers,
God bless them all would roll down there
with their bulldozers and there they'd
put these big concrete barriers up and
they put sand bags and all the windows
and they build machine gun nests on top.
And again,
they're doing this in the middle of like
mayhem.
Wow.
And then you'd have this secure combat
outpost.
And while they were doing that,
this is sort of was our,
our addition to this type of operation
was while they were doing this big
construction progress project,
obviously the situation was very
vulnerable for the American forces.
And so what we would do is I would push
our seals out into perimeter buildings
that were maybe a 200 or 300 yards away.
And so when the enemy would come to
attack,
we'd kill them.
What a crazy scene that must've been to
be taking these buildings and then
reinforcing them and turning them into
military bases and then one after
another as you're doing this too.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was,
it was an awesome effort and I think a
good number.
We put in one combat outpost and there
was the,
the uh,
army engineers put in 30,000 sandbags in
one combat outpost,
three buildings.
Just all good things.
A lot of sand out there.
Yeah,
no doubt.
No doubt about it.
Wow.
And so how many buildings did you guys
wind up taking overall?
Uh,
totally.
It probably a total of like 10 combat
outposts.
Each one having two,
three or four buildings.
And again,
let me clarify when I say we,
I'm talking about this massive effort of
the one one aed,
which is the,
the First Brigade,
First Armored Division and all the
battalions that were underneath them,
including one a Marine Corps battalion.
And the reason I'm pointing that out,
Joe,
is,
um,
those guys were just unbelievable us.
They were like war.
They were awesome.
You choked up.
Okay.
Yeah,
these guys were,
these guys were awesome.
They really were.
Yeah.
I can only imagine the emotional
attachment that you have to that.
Yeah.
And you know,
they,
you know,
you can look,
you can google navy seals and find,
you know,
20 million new stories about them.
Um,
and that's great.
But these guys,
you know,
to,
to have seen them,
uh,
kids,
you know,
because you know,
you're talking about earlier how the
seals,
you know,
guys like me,
this isn't what we want to do.
Well,
these guys didn't all necessarily have
that attitude.
And as a matter of fact,
the guys that were in Ramadi with us
when we first got there,
they were reserve unit out of
Pennsylvania,
the two to eight iron soldiers.
They were reservists.
These guys were teachers that like,
like what you see when they talk about
these reserves.
These guys were teachers and professors
and you know,
bakers and they had real jobs and real
world and wanting to get home to their
family.
And yet they were,
they're grinding it out against a
hardened enemy.
And so,
uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's a crazy thing to see and it's,
it's very humbling to be around people
like that.
It really is.
That was one of the things I would have
a hard time coach Halter fighter.
Cause I'll,
I'll look at our,
you know,
dissected person.
I'm like in about,
Kay,
let me see you fight me.
I'm going to go with you and I'm okay.
You have a hole here,
a hole here.
So are you looking just to fight to make
two paychecks,
three paychecks if cell then I guess
you're in the right area.
But if you're looking to be a real
champion,
if you're looking to be able to provide
for your family,
I mean I always thought we all,
all the time when I was in the UFC,
when that fought for the world
championship at one 35,
I also,
we're going to fucking full time job and
they'll be like,
do it fight for world championship.
You shouldn't be working.
I was like,
uh,
yeah because what have you,
I've lost the fight.
So now I,
I made what,
$14,000 because that what she made to
fight for the world title at one 35.
Yes.
That's,
well,
it's,
it's all public record.
So God damn,
and then that's why it's depressing.
So that's why I was still working.
Even when I fight in Modo,
I mean,
I made my money then I was like,
Kate,
every single thing I had in ufc up to
the dominant Cruz spite,
Eh,
when I brought them on,
they going to go towards,
I was like,
I was in Vegas.
It was almost like a vacation for me.
You know,
when Dana,
when Matt will call me,
he goes,
hey,
the UFC wants to know who want to fight.
Uh,
Katie,
I'm going where I was like,
I'll be like,
uh,
can I call you right back?
I need to call work to see if I could
stay off please.
And I will call my boss people hockey
now.
Hey,
um,
so ufc called,
they want to know is your job,
what were you doing?
Farming or working at a paper mill and
construction.
So we built,
uh,
basically sonic tubes.
So,
um,
and we also built the board.
So at this uh,
microphone came to you and it was in
protection.
It would be like a V board that would
protect it.
And that's where I was the guy who made
it.
And let's say you needed two and a half
inches or three inches,
four inches,
five inches,
whatever.
I would take it,
do the math,
put it in the computer and sit there and
go to g,
G,
G and I'll go one,
two,
three,
four.
Okay.
Those 10 there you go and do that all
day.
And then when I,
and not have my phone on me and that
will call me those,
hey doc once,
so if you want to fight,
and I'm like,
I'll run into the bathroom and like,
Hey,
what's up man?
He goes,
hey,
you know,
you usually want you to fight Kevin Modo
on February 5th,
my debut in UFC 211 I'll say,
hey,
let me see if I get a day off from work.
I go into my office,
they now say,
hey pete,
what's going on?
And he goes,
what's up DJ?
And I'm like,
Hey,
do you think I can have a week off to go
fight in a vegas?
He goes,
uh,
yeah,
let me see if I can work it out.
And then I'm like,
all right,
no,
not come out as,
hey,
I don't know.
Don't say yes.
I don't know yet.
Okay.
And he goes,
all right,
we'll just let me know.
Okay.
And then sure enough in barstow.
So yeah,
you get a week off.
And I was like,
Hey,
I can go.
And he goes,
all right,
I'll let sean shelby know you can fight.
That's how it was.
Are you still friends with your boss?
Yeah.
We still hang out with you.
Happy.
Oh yeah,
he's now,
well,
he said,
he said he would fire me before I quit
fighting and doing her old job because
in reality that's what's pay my fucking
bills.
That check was coming every single week.
It was keeping the lights on.
Fighting was not,
so that's why I tell kids all the time,
like,
man,
it would be just like it.
I was like,
no,
my friend be better than he.
Go to college,
get education.
Don't try to put yourself in a,
in a boat to where this all you have to
do.
You you have,
you know,
now it's worked out for me where I can,
I'm starting to,
you know,
branch out and they try to do other
things but that's how the reality was.
And so that's why I worked for time.
The dirtiness,
the humiliation.
No.
What are we gonna wrap this up
so fucked up.
You shouldn't be talking to on the air.
Listen,
nothing bad has been sad.
Beautiful.
Talking about aerial is I love dark
ones.
No,
no,
no.
I like,
uh,
my wife is like a high pink.
I like that.
Okay.
It seems real.
I wasn't real.
I don't want to go on the Strip club and
have them be able to get naked like
that.
I want them to like take nervous about,
oh what the realness.
I want to see like let's talk marks in
their leg.
Realness.
Oh,
sophomores.
Like I want real,
let's wrap this bitch up cause this is
going to go south.
Suck marks.
I just got back from Columbus,
Ohio and you're not allowed to be naked
there.
And so all the girls had pastries,
but they would have like darker nipple
looking pasty.
So it looked like they all just have
really big area,
all that dark Ariel and now it was
ridiculous.
You have to have a thin rubber sheet
over the outside of your nipple and if
you go outside you can just take her
shirt off cause it's legal and Columbus,
Ohio to just take your shirt off
outside.
But when you're inside at the Strip
club,
you have to put paste.
These are in Columbus.
It's legal to be topless.
If you're white,
it's been there for forever.
You can just walk around with,
no,
it's hilarious.
What a dumb business.
Hey,
are you upset at all?
The freedom that you have with girl's
nipples out there on the street will
come on inside.
Come on and shout.
We'll show you a watered down version of
what's available right outside our door.
We'll judge you.
Chrissy teagan's,
a nipple warrior.
Who's that?
I don't know.
I just read it the other way.
She's a nipple warrior.
I don't even know the Fuck Debbie Morris
kids in Nipple Warrior,
the Nipple Warriors.
What does that mean?
They're like,
they want everyone to be able to see
their nipples.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Like I'll really sheer shirt or
something like that.
No,
no,
no.
They want to go
do Demi Moore's kid.
She just walks around shirtless.
Barb,
you gotta be like 20 or something.
You're talking about Jay Leno.
I know.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Something.
One of the names riders had rain or
something.
Rickles recalls what it fucking,
what are the more kids?
The more time Roger Moore,
whatever it's fucking on.
You're getting more and more.
Demi Moore is fucking Joe.
What about like five minutes now?
Her name is rumor,
rumor,
more type and river.
More uh,
a nipple.
Dove.
Jay Leno.
He's a little kid alone.
No,
it's a fucking grown up.
It's a real grownup type.
The goddamn
fucking nipple.
Rubber Nipple.
Yeah.
That's rap.
James Burke Christ.
Your Ladies and gentlemen.